[Musique]
lundi 15 janvier bonsoir et bienvenue
dans cette édition du 78 sur TV 78 voici
les titres de
l'actualité cela fait une semaine
désormais que le plan grand froid a été
déclenché dans les Evelin il prévoit
notamment le renforcement des marudes
auprès des sans-abris à l'antenne de
viroflet véisie de la croix- rouge deux
équipes de bénévoles et un salarié ont
été ajoutés en renfort nous les avons
suivi le temps d'une soirée c'était l'un
de ses premiers déplacements en tant que
Premier ministre Gabriel Atal s'est
rendu au collège saint-Exup Perry
d'andrésie en fin de semaine dernière il
était accompagné de la nouvelle ministre
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
et des sports et des Jeux Olympiques
amélier ouea Castera retour sur la
visite c'est un succès qui vaut de l'or
le Rugby Club de Versailles a enfin
renoué avec la victoire ctire après une
série de 7 défaites d'affilé en fédéral
2 les ivelinois se sont imposés hier au
bout du suspense 2420 contre plus anné
dans la 12e journée les hommes de Tiffen
charol sortent ainsi momentanément de la
zone rouge et puis la suite de nos
interviews avec les maires de 50 ans en
Eveline dans l'invité du 78 c'est en
2uxème partie d'émission ils viendront
en plateau tout au long du mois de
janvier ce soir nous recevons Bertron
Ouillon maire de manie Lamo et avec moi
en plateau pour ce début d'émission
Michel midoro bonsoir bonsoir de la
rédaction TV 78 alors aujourd'hui c'est
le Blue Monday est-ce que vous
connaissez le principe je crois que
c'est la journée la plus déprimante de
l'année je crois c'est ça c'est le 3è
lundi de janvier c'est chaque Annex à zé
est-ce que vous êtes déprimé aujourd'hui
Michel al déprimé non mais il fait très
froid donc forcément un peu déprime
j'avoue en tout cas moi je suis très
content de vous avoir en plateau et vous
nous présentez dans quelques instants
l'actualité sportive dans dans les
Yvelines on jouait malgré le froid sur
les terrains yvelinois ce weekend quel
est le programme aujourd'hui alors on
parlera notamment de Versailles qui a
perdu en National qui a perdu 2 à0
c'était contre Gaul versaill par contre
qui a réussi à gagner en 32e de finale
de Coupe gambardéas c'est du football et
on parlera également de Caroline Garcia
qui s'est sorti du premier tour de cette
Open d'Australie c'est du tennis elle
est saint-germainoise et elle sera au
deème tour je crois qu'on parlera aussi
d'un record du monde battu dans les
evelines ce weekend ce sera tout à
l'heure dans le
78 le s'est installé désormais depuis
plus d'une semaine maintenant face à la
situation les associations se mobilisent
et ont renforcé leur action notamment
les marotes c'est le cas de la Croix
Rouge des Yvelines Aurélie lafeille et
Julien lur ont suivi une équipe le temps
d'une soirée à viroflet véisi la
préparation c'est tout simple donc notre
carburant principal c'est ici vous avez
les bouillards d'eau chaude puisqu'on a
besoin d'eau chaude pour faire du café
et pour faire des soupes 5 6 7 8 des
températures négatives qui dur et rendre
la vie dans la rue encore plus difficile
ce soir- làà les marudeur de la Croix
Rouge de l'antenne viroflet véis
s'organise on a pris un sac poubelle ou
pas on va préparer différentes choses
donc on va préparer du sucre des petites
cuillères on va préparer des des kit
hygiènees si les gens nous demandent des
brosses à dents des rasoirs des choses
comme ça on a on a un peu de quoi leur
donner et puis on prend toujours
quelques boîtes de gâteau le 8 janvier
dernier le préfet desivlin a activé le
plan grand froid conséquence l'antenne
rajoué deux équipes de bénévoles et une
de salariés chaque soir en ce moment on
a au lieu d'avoir trois ou quatre
équipes qui tournent en tout on en a
plutôt 7 au 8 ça permet de faire des
marudes qu'on appelle des maraudes
exploratoires c'est qu'on se promène
vraiment dans les villes on va là où on
nous appelle mais on va aussi se
promener dans les endroits où on sait
que parfois il y a des gens qui sont
pour pour voir s'ils ont s'ils ont
besoin de nous le groupe de bénévoles
appelle la régulatrice tout le long de
la maraude pour qu'elle les tienneent
former des appels de détresse les gens
appellent le
115 le 115 appelle la régule et nous on
appelle la régule donc il nous donne des
ce qu'on appelle des missions et si
jamais il y a plus de mission B on on
fait un peu le tour dans Versailles à
des endroits où on sait que
potentiellement il y a
quelqu'un vous voulez quelque chose un
pull des gants non ah c'est la propos de
manger sac jeaelle 115 pour manger
j'appelle 115 pour 4h puis m' porte
manger ici la soupe devient souvent un
prétexte pour rentrer en contact avec
ses hommes et ses femmes les membres de
l'association profitent de cet échange
pour orienter le bénéficiaire vers un
centre d'hébergement ou une préfecture
cinq personnes ont été accompagnées par
l'équipe ce soir-là ce soir on a on a
très peu de gens hein on a on a vu
quelques personnes qu' fait très froid
et le plan grand froid a été déclenché
donc il y a plus de gens qui ont été mis
à l'abri il y a plus de place disponible
et et puis quand il fait très froid les
gens il se ils se mettent dans des
parkings ils trouvent des endroits pour
se mettre à l'abri le plan grand froid
est toujours activé des températures
plus clémentes sont attendu pour
mercredi 17 janvier avant de rechuter
jeudi les prévisions annoncent Mo 3 degr
à Versailles on a du
canard le point présent sur le reste des
actualités dans les
ivelines
[Musique]
Michel la nouvelle ministre du Travail
de la santé des solidarités Catherine
Vautrin était cet après-midi en
déplacement dans le département elle
s'est notamment rendue à l'Agence France
travail de Guy encour pour échanger
autour de deux thématiques
l'accompagnement des entreprises pour
favoriser le retour à l'emploi et le
renforcement de ses aides auprès des
publics pour rappel depuis le 1er
janvier 2024 Pôle Emploi est devenu
France travail l'objectif contribuer au
plein emploi on reviendra sur cette
cette information dans notre édition de
demain la communauté israélite de
Versailles est en deil Samuel Sandler
responsable laïque de la communauté juif
de Versailles décédé ce vendredi 12
janvier 2024 d'une crise cardiaque à
l'âge de 77 ans les membres de la
communauté israélite de Versailles lui
ont rendu un dernier hommage au
cimetière juif de la rue persching à
versaill père et grand-père de trois
victimes de l'attaque terroriste de de
l'école ozaratora en mars 2012 à
Toulouse Samuel Sandler était devenu une
figure emblématique de la mémoire des
victimes du terrorisme depuis l'annonce
de sa mort les hommages se multiplient
sur les réseaux sociaux Valérie pces
Présidente de la Région Île-de-France et
Jean-Jacques Brot préfet des iblines
expriment leur tristesse sur X ex
Twitter tout comme François de maierre
maire de Versailles on l'écoute c'est
une grande tristesse parce que c'était
un homme pour lequel je crois tout le
monde avait une très grande admiration
pour nous tous c'était un model de
dignité je crois que c'est le mot
dignité c'était un homme incroyablement
digne et et vraiment qui forçait
l'admiration son épouse myiam se rendra
samedi en Israël elle sera notamment
accompagnée de la conseillère municipale
Muriel Vassel Samuel Sandler sera
enterré dimanche au cimetière de
Jérusalem au côté de son fils et de ses
petit-fils information économique à
présent avec ode le leader des service à
domicile qui organise un job dating
national ce mardi et dans les Yvelines
cette agence sont concernées pas besoin
de cvni de lettrre de motivation les SEP
agences iblinoises vont vous accueill
pour rencontrer directement les équipes
au2 en toute simplicité autour d'un café
le but laisser une chance au plus grand
nombre des postes d'assistants ménager
de vie ou encore garde d'enfants seront
notamment proposés si vous êtes
intéressé rendez-vous dans l'une des SEP
agences des yvelin une collecte de
produits d'hygiène et de première
nécessité est organisé demain à Monin le
Bretonneux c'est l'Union des étudiants
des ivelines qui est à l'origine de
cette initiative cette collecte se
déroulera de 11h à 18h devant le
Carrefour Market de montinil le
breteneux le but redistribuer ses
produits aux étudiants et étudiante la
semaine du 22 janvier éclat d'œil
insolite pour terminer avec une date
importante aujourd'hui le le 15 janvier
pour le CIRANO à Versailles il y a 60
ans les Beatles jouaient leur premier
concert en France au CIRANO de
Versailles c'était le 15 janvier 1964 au
côté de triniy Lopez et Sylvie Vartan
pour l'occasion les botleg Beatles
groupe de reprise des Beatles propose de
revivre cet événement mythique à
l'identique ce soir à 20h de 20h à 22h
au cinéma UGC à Cano mais
malheureusement c'est déjà complet on
comprend pour pas on pourra pas prendre
de place pour ce petit clin d'œuil au
Beatles donc qui ont joué il y a 60 ans
jour pour jour à Versailles c'était leur
première date en France merci Michel et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi prês de
chez vous vous êtes témoins d'une
actualité qui vous fait réagir dans les
evelines n'hésitez pas à la partager sur
les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78 news Michel vous en parlait
dans ses informations avec la venue de
Catherine Vautrin cet après-midi dans
les yelines vendredi c'est le Premier
ministre nouveau Premier ministre
Gabriel Atal qui était en déplacement
dans un collège d'andrésie accompagné de
la ministre de l'Éducation nationale et
des Sports Amélie oua ctera ils ont pu
faire le point sur la nouvelle feuille
de route du gouvernement concernant
l'éducation et Gabriel Gontier et
Patrick Jacques de dixmud comment ça
va on va super travaillez bien premier
bain de foule et premier selfie pour le
nouveau Premier ministre Gabriel hatal
et la ministre de l'Éducation et des
Sports Amélie ouea Castera pour leur
premier déplacement ensemble les
ministres se sont rendus au collège
saint-exupéri d'andrésie l'objectif
présenter leur nouvelle feuille de route
sur le choc des savoirs et réaffirmer la
volonté du gouvernement de rendre
l'éducation prioritaire l'école sera une
priorité absolue du gouvernement je sais
d'expérience que pour ce qui concerne
l'école comme dans beaucoup d'autres
domaines ce qui compte ce ne sont pas
que les mots ce sont les actes et donc
on va continuer à agir sans relâche pour
l'école de la République avec un
objectif absolu élever le niveau général
à l'école durant près d'une heure les
ministres ont pu échanger à H clos avec
les enseignants et les élèves la libre
parole a circulé entre les élèves les
équipes éducatives donc il a été
question de plusieurs sujets à la fois
la question de l'apprentissage des
fondamentaux et donc les élèves sont
revenus sur le dispositif mis en place
les bénéfices que ça pouvait leur
apporter et puis les équipes éducatives
comment elles étaient structurées une
façon aussi de rassurer les inquiétude
concernant le double ministère dont
hérite Amélie oua casterra mon message
pour la communauté éducative c'est que
je serai une ministre à fond une
ministre à fond avec eux une ministre à
fond derrière eux absolument déterminé
et je démontrerai à chacun de ces
acteurs ma disponibilité auprès d'eux
une année qui s'annonce chargée pour la
nouvelle ministre qui devra jongler
entre les défis de l'éducation et des
Jeux Olympiques et parinlympiqu qui se
tiendront cet été on ouvre la page sport
dans le
[Musique]
78 et on débute ces actualités sportives
Michel avec du rugby versaill qui
restait sur 7 matchs sans victoire en
fédéral 2 s'est rassuré ce dimanche
contre l'quip l'équipe de plousané les
joueurs de la cité royale se sont
imposés 24 à 20 le résumé du match des
images de méanie
poy c'était le match de la peur ce
dimanche 14 janvier les Versaillais
avant-derniers de la poule 8 de fedéral
2 recevaient le dernier plusousanné tout
a mal commencé pour les ivelinois
dépassés en début de match il concède
deux essais mais versaill se reprend
inscrit un essai et arrive à égaliser
avant la mi-temps le score à la posuse
partout de pas virer avec du retard au
point à la mi-temps c'est important
mentalement parce que c'est là où on
s'évite un doute trop important dans les
vissière en seconde période Versailles
accélère et arrive à trouver des brèches
dans la défense de plusousané il
remporte la rencontre 24 à 20 malgré
quelques frayeurs en fin de match on
était quand même sur un cycle de SEP
défaites d'affilé et mine de rien c'est
quelque chose qui est très présent
mentalement essayer de se sortir de
cette spirale négative c'est très dur et
je pense qu'on retiendra surtout
aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir réussi à
briser cette spirale et de de gagner
tout simplement de gagner et de
retrouver le goût de la victoire
aujourd'hui oui c'est respirable mais
bon le le job est fait la victoire est
là et ça nous fait souffler un petit peu
grâce à cette victoire les Versaillais
peuvent respirer au classement ils
sortent de la zone de relégation et se
retrouvent à la 8e place de leur poule
de fédéral 2 l'équipe flirte toujours
avec la relégation aujourd'hui
c'estrirable parce que c'est des matchs
de maintien c'est des matchs du bas de
tableau il va falloir être fort
mentalement avec des équipe qui
forcément sont sont un petit peu
fragilisé comme nous prochain match pour
les Versaillais ce dimanche 21 janvier
les joueurs de la cité royale joueront
un derby sulfureux sur le terrain de
plaisir le match est programmé à 15h15
une victoire permettra à Versailles de
installé en milieu de
classement toujours à Versailles mais
cette fois-ci en football dans le
championnat de National versaill a connu
la défaite à extérieur sur le terrain du
golf FC les joueurs de la cité royale se
sont inclinés 2 à 0 en concédant un but
dans chaque période mauvaise opération
au classement pour les joueurs zivinois
il se retrouveent à la 11e place du
championnat mais ils ne sont qu'à 9
points de la deème place ils joueront
lundi prochain à domicile contre martig
B versille qui ne brille pas en le
championnat national mais chez les
jeunes en coupe gambardellaa ils ont
brillé avec cette coupe Gambardella qui
est en fait la Coupe de France des
jeunes c'est ça exactement deux fois
mené au score les jeunes versaillais se
sont qualifiés pour les 16e de finale de
la Coupe gambardellaa les U19 ont gagné
au tir au but 5 à 4 face à l'équipe de
La Maladrerie qui évolue aussi en R1 ils
ont gagné ce match alors qu'ils étaient
à 10 contre 11 pendant 80 minutes le
tirage au sort se fera ce jeudi 18
janvier à midi du tennis à présent on
joue en ce moment l'Open d'Australie il
y a des ivelinois sur les cours fortune
diverse pour nos ivelinois Caroline
Garcia originaire de Saint-Jean Manly
s'est imposé 64 76 face à la japonaise
Naomi Osaka elle a pu profiter d'un bon
service avec 13 a pendant le match au
prochain tour l'ivelinoise tête de série
numéro 16 joura contre la Polonaise
Magdalena frache de son côté Arthur
rinerkn lui aussi originaire de
saint-germainl a été éliminé au premier
tour face à Pavel Kotov en 57 on espère
que Caroline Garcia ira loin dans ce
tournoi il y avait aussi du CME sur
piste ce weekend ce samedi avait lieu
les 6H du Vélodrome national de 50 ans
en ieline un événement organisé pour la
4e fois par la structure en partenariat
avec le club local de le cvéisi 78 au
total 21 équipes ont participé à ce
rendez-vous ils étaient divisés en 5
catégorie objectif réaliser le plus de
tours poss possible on écoute l'une des
participantes marine clloarek au micro
de
tv78 en fait c'est une habitude qu'on a
pris en début d'année ça nous permet de
bien nous amuser entre amis et puis et
puis voilà de profiter de surtout faire
des efforts au Chud nous ça nous tient à
cœur aussi de répondre présent à tous
les événements qu' peut mettre en place
le record desciseh a été battu André
Valentin Manu Guérinel Matis Guérinel
elas Jobard du Paris cyclisme olympique
ont réalisé 1101 tours de piste
275,250 km 3 km de plus que l'ancien
record enfin un mot des jeux olympqu
bravo à eux bien sûr ça se rapproche he
les Jeux Olympiques pour cette année
2024 on connaî deux noms qui vont porter
la flamme olympique dans les ivelines
oui Grégory Roger jquel figure du club
d'athlétisme de saint-germainle fait
partie des relayeurs sélectionnés par le
Conseil départemental desvines l'homme
de 92 ans avait déjà eu la chance de
porter la torche olympique à l'occasion
des GEOS divers de Grenoble il y a 57
ans on connaît aussi un deuxème nom il
s'agit de bris parinet arbitre sur les
terrains de Ligue 1 est rattaché au
district des imines de football la la
flamme olympique passera le 23 juillet à
dans les iblelines 200 relayeurs
passeront par manentelaville Les Mureaux
poiss aigu en cours via le Golf National
Versailles Saint-Rémi les chevuses et
rambouillé merci Michel pour toutes ces
actualités sportives et avant de passer
à l'invité du 78 on va jeter un coup
d'œil aux prévisions météo de
demain avec des températures qui restent
négatives il fera jusqu'à -5°gr demain
matin dans le département c'est dans le
sud Yveline qu'il fera le plus froid le
ciel sera voilé sur l' semble du
territoire l'après-midi même condition
avec un Mercure qui repasse dans le
positif 3°gr à mant-elajolie 2°gr dans
les secteurs de Versailles Rambouillet
et Oudan et ce mardi 16 janvier nous
fêterons les marcelles tout de suite
l'invité du
[Musique]
78 tout au long du mois de janvier tv78
reçoit les mares de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline pour parler de l'année 2024 dans
leur commune et ce soir c'est Bertrand
Ouillon qui est avec nous bonsoir maire
de Mani lesamau vice-président également
de 50 ans en Yveline délégué aux espaces
verts et à l'agriculture bonne année à
vous déjà et à toutes les manioises tous
les manicois qui nous regardent
qu'est-ce que vous retenez de l'année
2023 déjà dans votre commune euh une
année 2023 sur les chapeaux de roues
avec énormément de de travaux engagé qui
se terminaient qui se
poursuivait et puis énormément aussi de
dynamique avec toutes les associations
beaucoup de liens finalement entre tous
les habitants avec voilà un max
d'activité et on est prêt là pour les
Jeux Olympiques et Paralympiques on va
parler des projets 2024 dans dans votre
commune juste un mot sur cette fin
d'année qui a été agitée à Man liamo
vous êtes revenu d'ailleurs sur ce
climat difficile lors de votre cérémonie
de vœux à la population la semaine
dernière un habitant de votre commune a
été menacé de mort en voulant s'informer
sur un projet de lieu de culte porté par
l'association des musulmans de manilé
amamoo il a dû quitter la commune vous
aussi dans dans cette affaire vous avez
été visé par des menaces des incitations
à la violence et des injures cette
fois-ci venant plutôt des détracteurs du
projet vous avez déposé cinq plaintes en
ce sens comment allez-vous aujourd'hui
est-ce que le climat s'est apaisé depuis
à manilamo alors moi d'abord je vais pas
rentrer dans les basses polémiques
inopportunes d'ailleurs euh qui ont pu
avoir lieu euh courant novembre et
décembre euh je laisse ça à ceux qui ont
voulu les mener euh
ensuite
euh en effet j'ai fait l'objet depuis 4
semaines d'un jure de menace de mise au
banc avec des tournées dans des médias
euh qu'on connaît pour leur extrême euh
avec un certain nombre aussi de de
désinformations
euh je sais que la
gendarmerie les services de la
préfecture sur euh l'ensemble des des
renseignements sont à mes côtés me me
soutiennent aussi dans dans ces moments
euh il faut savoir que d'une part je ne
renoncerai jamais aux valeurs de la
République que les choses soient très
claires par rapport à ces groupuscules
d'extrême droite ou qui qui tentent de
nous
déstabiliser et puis de manière plus
générale la responsabilité d'un maire
euh c'est à la fois d'agir dans le cadre
des valeurs de la République euh agir
dans le cadre des principes de laïcité
et agir dans le cadre de la loi et c'est
ce que je fais sur ce dossier comme tous
les autres en lien évidemment avec les
services de la préfecture donc c'est un
projet qui va suivre son cours est ce
qui verra le jour certains médias
parlent d'une vente du terrain qui est
situé rue André hautebourg qui serait
peut-être suspendu un terrain qui
appartient aujourd'hui à l'agglomération
de 50 ans Yveline j'invite tout le monde
à faire d'une part attention à ce qu'il
dit et d'autre part à faire attention à
l'ensemble des fake news qui peuvent qui
peuvent voir le jour pour l'st c'est pas
d'actualité pas du tout pas du tout euh
il y a une délibération qui a été prise
à l'unanimité par l'agglomération
c'était en septembre dernier cette
délibération nous permet puisque c'est
l'agglomération qui est propriétaire de
ce terrain nous permet d'étudier ce
terrain on a eu une rencontre avec les
riverins qui ont un certain nombre
d'interrogation par rapport au
stationnement par rapport à
d'éventuelles nuisan de bruit aussi avec
un nouvel équipement public autour de
chez eux évidemment tout ça on le
regarde mais on le regarde avec les
personnes concernées alors
projetons-nous sur l'année 2024 avec des
nouveautés notamment pour le le service
public de proximité les habitants on le
sait ils sont attachés alors la
nouveauté de cette année 2024 c'est que
les habitants pourront de nouveau
réaliser leur demande de carte
d'identité et de passeport directement
au service étatcivil de la mairie de
manilamo vous me disiez avant de débuter
cette émission ça faisait 20 ans à peu
près qu'on pouvait plus le faire ça ça
devait faire à peu près 20 ans euh suite
à la mise en place euh des euh des
outils biométriques euh à l'époque
l'État avait choisi de sélectionner un
certain nombre de collectivités de
mémoire il devait y en avoir une
trentaine maximum dans les ivelines la
commune de manilamo n'avait pas été
sélectionnée à cette époque on a eu un
certain nombre de retours
d'interrogation d'habitants en début
d'année euh on s'est retourné vers vers
la préfecture euh on a proposé euh à la
préfecture d'être candidat pour pouvoir
accueillir ces euh ce ce terminal pour
pouvoir prendre donc les cartes
d'identité les passeports directement
dans notre hôtel de ville on l'a
travaillé aussi avec évidemment les
agents de notre service état cvil euh
les services préfectoraux ont accepté
notre proposition euh là on est encore
en phase de test euh et j'espère que
nous allons pouvoir ouvrir tout ça là
tout début février donc c'est c'est
imminent et on en est ravi et dans les
nouveautés aussi il y a euh ce qu'
concerne enfin en ce qui concerne les
places de crèche le multiaccueil
familial et et collectif compte des
places supplémentaires euh quel est le
travail de la commune sur le sujet des
crèches alors il faut savoir que de
manière générale une commune c'est le
service de proximité le service public
de proximité donc on intervient dans
beaucoup de domaines euh le domaine de
la garde d'enfants en éteint euh le
domaine de la petite enfance et du suivi
de cette petite enfance en éint et euh
dans ce cadre-là donc on a un service
municipal à la fois en accueil collectif
à la fois en accueil familial euh et
aujourd'hui on le conforte avec un
accueil euh de de de nouvelles places
qui va permettre par exemple à des
familles de pouvoir aussi reprendre un
emploi de de pouvoir finalement
reprendre aussi un certain nombre
d'autonomie et nous on les accompagne
pour pouvoir faire tout ça donc ça ça
fait partie des nouveautés alors l'une
de vos priorités c'est aussi le lien
entre les habitants notamment le lien
intergénérationnel il y aura donc en
2024 la la remise en place de de
l'accompagnement des seigors isolé très
concrètement en fait c'est des bénévoles
qui font les courses de de ces seiors
qui leur rendent visite pourquoi c'est
nécessaire justement de d'accompagner
ces Seigneur isolés alors toute cette
partie là avait été un peu mise à mal
pendant la période de crise sanitaire et
on on remet en place ces dispositifs le
le l'accompagnement en minibus pour
aller faire ses courses ça permet à la
fois évidemment d'aider des personnes
qui n'ont pas qui ne peuvent pas être
véhiculées de les accompagner dans les
dans les rayons mais aussi tout
simplement de discuter et de de passer
le temps en en faisant ces courses mais
au-delà de ça il y a aussi des visites
directement chez eux euh pour pouvoir
pareil ben avoir un brin de discussion
euh au moment des repas de partager un
repas avec avec ces personnes et puis
dernière nouveauté en date c'est des
après-midis jeux euh qui euh qui sont
proposés dans notre boutique de quartier
au centre social euh où les seiors
découvrent des jeux qu'il n'auraient
peut-être jamais eu l'occasion de
découvrir accompagnés par euh un de nos
services civique euh qui euh fait
énormément de choses pour continuer de
créer ce lien et au-delà de ça euh de
créer du lien aussi entre les seniors et
les plus jeunes euh notamment via notre
service en France avec un certain nombre
d'activités découverte de danse de jeux
aussi euh il faut créer ce lien-là parce
que les les seniors ont on ont cette
cette expérience cette sagesse qui est
tellement utile pour les plus jeunes il
y a un projet dont on parle qui concerne
justement le lien intergénérationnel on
en parle depuis à peu près 2 ans
maintenant à manilamo c'est un habitat
projet d'habitat intergénérationnel et
solidaire innovant qui doit voir le jour
aller des Capucines il est porté par
l'association maison Madeleine est
soutenue par la commune on en est où
concrètement aujourd'hui alors
aujourd'hui
l'association doit déposer son permis
dans les prochains jours donc on arrive
à une nouvelle pH phase de de ce projet
qui est un projet innovant donc qui dit
projet innovant dit projet qui sort un
petit peu des cases classiques et donc
qui prend du temps mais on a une
association qui est des bénévoles de
cette association qui sont
particulièrement motivé la commune les
accompagne pas à pas et on espère que
Ben dès le dépôt du permis de construire
ensuite après les phases administrative
que la construction puisse démarrer pour
pouvoir enfin avoir cet habitat qui
puisse être partagé entre des seniors
des personnes en situation de handicap
des des étudiants familles et puis qui
devrai être associé à une micro crèche
et puis un café solidaire qui sera tenu
par les résidents mais ouvert à tous les
habitants un projet dont on va avoir du
concret là très très prochainement
dernier dossier que je voulais aborder
avec vous celui de la transition
écologique et énergétique alors vous
avez entamé à à manilé un processus de
déminéralisation des cours d'école celle
de Jean-Baptiste corau par exemple a été
inauguré l'année dernière ça va se
poursuivre cette année alors on a eu des
travaux qui ont eu lieu dans les cours
du groupe scolaire andrégide euh
maternel et élémentaire j'espère qu'on
va pouvoir inaugurer en début d'année
euh vous parliez de météo tout à l'heure
les pluies d'iluviennne que nous av
avons pu avoir en fin d'année ont un peu
perturbé le le calendrier mais on va y
parvenir et puis on se lance sur euh
d'autres cours pour des travaux que nous
espérons durant l'été à la fois sur les
cours justement de la maison des tout
petits et puis donc l'accueil collectif
de de crèche qu'on évoquéit tout à
l'heure et puis on va engager les
discussions avec l'équipe éducative de
l'école maternelle Francis Jamin la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments si
se se poursuit il y a notamment la
l'hôtel de ville qui a subi des travaux
l'an passé ça va se poursuivre du coup
aussi cette année alors voilà on est
là-dessus sur un plan pluriannuel qui
est basé sur les consommations en tout
cas les les bâtiments les plus
énergivores donc tris ont déjà été ont
déjà été rénovés l'Hôtel de Ville 2023
était le 3e les travaux se poursuivent
sur le gymnase Auguste de laun qu'on
espère inaugurer en cette année
olympique et paralympique et nous avons
obtenu 1,2 million d'euros de la part de
l'État avec le fond vert et ce qui
s'appelle le désil et donc on va pouvoir
entamer notre 5e rénovation énergétique
qui est le groupe scolaire corosamin et
alors sur cette thématique aussi on en
parlait avant de débuter cette émission
une étude qui va être lancée à manilé am
sur les énergies renouvelables estce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus
alors on a on accueille un data center
qui est tééhous qui continue de
s'implanter sur la commune en
agrandissant son Data Center et avec cet
agrandissement ils nous ont proposé de
mettre à disposition de la collectivité
euh la chaleur dite fatale donc la
chaleur du data center euh ce qui fait
que nous entamons aujourd'hui une étude
qui est financée par l'ADEM et la région
et cette étude doit nous permettre de
savoir si nous pourrions chauffer notre
commune euh donc les équipements publics
des des logements collectif et puis on a
associé aussi la commune voisine de
sint-réille les chevreuses dans ce
domaine maintenant l'étude c'est une
étude technique juridique financière et
en fonction de ces résultats on va voir
derrière ce qu'on va pouvoir faire donc
euh on verra ce qu'il en est cette année
pour manilamo deux dernières choses pour
terminer tous ces projets on le sait
sont menés dans un contexte de plus en
plus compliqué pour les communes qui ont
de moins en moins de ressources pour
financer ces différentes mesures dont on
a parlé est-ce que vous vous réservez le
droit d'activer le levier impôts local
cette année est-ce que vous allez
augmenter les impôts locaux à à manilamo
alors on l'a utilisé en début d'année
dernière ce qui nous a permis d'ailleurs
de pouvoir financer un beaucoup
d'investissements euh qui sont cruciaux
puisque c'est des investissements pour
préparer l'avenir et notamment toute
cette transition écologique que que
j'évoqua euh on se réserve toujours ce
droit-là euh euh c'est une possibilité
c'est malheureusement aujourd'hui la
dernière possibilité qui reste aux
collectivités puisque les dotations
globales de de fonctionnement ont
totalement disparu de la part de l'État
et aujourd'hui les seuls financements
que nous arrivons à obtenir sont des
financements sur quelques
investissements pour lesquels nous
devons monter des très très gros
dossiers euh on le fait on fait aussi
toutes les économies
qui sont possibles dans la gestion de de
l'ensemble de nos services publics mais
encore une fois le service public c'est
un indispensable pour les habitants et
une commune qui ne propose plus de
restauration scolaire qui ne propose
plus de de de garde en petite enfance en
enfance ben c'est une commune en fait
qui Meur et dans laquelle les habitants
ne peuvent plus vivre en 20 secondes
Bertron on donne une carte blanche au
maire pour terminer cette séquence
d'interview vous abordez le sujet que
que vous souhaitez qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez dire pour terminer cette
interview ben l'année 2024 pour manilamo
euh c'est la fraternité plus fort euh
c'est-à-dire que on on a depuis
plusieurs années euh mixé à la fois les
valeurs républicaines et et la devise
olympique euh et la fraternité flufort
ben euh ça fait partie de nos essentiels
pour vivre en communauté pour pouvoir se
serrer les coudes et pour pouvoir
avancer et lutter contre toutes les
haines possible puisque sans fraternité
la démocratie devient une imposture je
l'ai évoqué à plusieurs reprises ce sont
des mots de d'Antoine de saintexupéri et
c'est ce qui devrait guider tout le
monde merci d'avoir été avec nous
Bertron Houillon je rappelle maire de
Mani Lamo une nouvelle fois bonne année
à vous et également à Mani Lamo pour
cette année 2000 24 voilà c'est la fin
du 78 merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve demain pour une nouvelle
édition belle soirée sur
[Musique]
tv78